in a society filled with human
innovation one invention stands out
above them all
the one that has become the obsession of
the modern world
money money was not just an intervention
it was a mental revolution created a
system of trust an elaborate tie binds
us all together it connected the world
spending merchants across continents and
searches of far-off riches exchange was
the engine that drove the progress of
civilization and money was the fuel it
allowed us to specialize turning hunters
into blacksmith art soldier and King
money is what made the world modern
[Music]
we have taken it dizzying levels of
complexity from gold coins to bits of
information stored in the cloud the
history of money is the history of us
every coin stone and shale symbol what
we have valued who we have served and
how our culture's evolved it has become
a language that all humans speak this is
a story of how money made us modern how
it opened the globe and spread
ideologies transforming the ancient
world into a complex civilization of
merchants mercenaries industrialists and
billionaires
this is origin
[Music]
Oh